growing body of research this is more
dog stories Lakes pet ownership to the
emotional well-being of children a
review of 22 studies found that kids who
grow up with animals are more likely to
have higher self-esteem better cognitive
development and more social skills in a
New York Times article
psychologist and CBS News contributor
Lisa d'amour explains that older kids
can especially benefit that article what
do teenagers need ask the family dog
it's online right now you can read it
the dogs not online there's a family dog
online that's a interesting question
good morning Lisa
the dogs give teenagers well for
starters dogs don't judge right and
teenagers spend a lot of time being
judged there are a lot of adults who
don't like teenagers and teenagers know
this and even those of us who really
like teenagers we're often giving them
feedback or encouraging them to grow and
I think for teenagers you know if
they're feeling terrible about like some
quiz from last week the dogs not going
to be like well maybe you should have
studied more do you write about
emotional and physical intimacy that I
thought was interesting what do you mean
all of us need emotional and physical
intimacy for teenagers those can be
pretty complicated to come by right that
if you're upset as a teenager maybe you
need a hug but you're not always going
to hug your parents you may or may not
be in a relationship where that makes
sense the dog is there the cat is there
to be hugged often when I ask teenagers
like how they recover from a long hard
day if they're very upset they will tell
me oh I go get the cat and we get in bed
or I roll around on the floor with a dog
and the research actually bears this out
like we have a lot of research showing
that contact with an animal does reduce
stress it lowers heart rate at lowers
blood pressure animals are like a
totally reliable cuddle buddy right and
teenagers maybe more than people of
other ages need a reliable cuddle cuddle
buddy in a recent study found that of
what 38% of people between 15 and 21 say
that social media sort of impacts how
they're feeling how does a pet play a
role when you look at all of the major
influences right now that teens are
faced with every day so right when
teenagers aren't being judged by adults
they're often judging one another right
and you know do you look good enough for
your years is your social standing good
enough and again the pet does not care
right the pet doesn't care if you're
cool the pet doesn't care if you have
temples like the pet loves you just as
you are 100 percent in your corner again
everybody needs this but I think
teenagers may especially me so what
happens if a pet isn't an option in some
households I'm like yours yeah but what
happened it won't always make sense
right for families to have pets and also
not all teenagers connect with pets
right I mean the answer is not that
everybody runs out and gets their
teenager a pet but what pets teach us is
what teenagers need teenagers need to be
accepted teenagers need affection they
also need a way to give affection that
doesn't feel complicated or loaded
teenagers need unconditional regard the
other thing they need is to be in the
here and now right and pets are great at
being in the here and now
you keep saying dogs don't care about
what happened to you at school they
don't care about how you look but what's
interesting is that dogs do care about
emotional well-being they pick up on
cues and they will go to somebody right
ya know so dogs are extremely attuned to
physical cues from adults and and
children and teenagers and so if they
notice that you're different they're
gonna be drawn to you and a lot of times
you do hear stories of people saying
like I was crying and the dog came up
and licked my tears right or noticed
that and just you know to think about
what it means to be a kid or a teenager
and you can feel so alone and so lonely
and if you come home and you're not
yourself and the pet picks it up and
it's drawn to you well I know I know
it's good for us is it good for them do
you think the dog is everything god they
get on my is it good for the dog the dog
is something I love to be loved to be
least loved hated ways to make it Hansel
love is a good thing yeah wherever you
can get it thank you very much